well I've been traveling around the
world looking at some of the more
extraordinary ants and I'm often asked
about the parallels between ants and
humans are there any well it turns out
there are a reason that is so is that
ants like humans can have societies in
the millions
that's far larger even than a bumblebee
colony and many of the attributes of an
ant colony like a human society depends
on its size I've found so the amount of
information flowing through the colony
the communications the control of the
environment around the colony
self-reliance declines as colonies get
bigger and more division of labor occurs
there can be teams and assembly lines
that form in bigger societies there's
more infrastructure things like mass
transit emerge and large ant societies
even features of the market economy come
out in the larger ant societies one
thing that's unique between humans and
ants is a capacity for warfare which
emerges in the large societies of ants
so there's more risk-taking in general
as societies get bigger so I've gone
around the world looking in many cases
for these large societies with their
large scale processes like we've just
mentioned but some of the really cool
things happen in the small societies too
and one pattern that has been found in
humans by Louise Betancourt at the Los
Alamos labs for example but it's obvious
to most people is that humans when
societies get bigger when cities get
bigger things seem to accelerate and
turns out ants show the same patterns so
I've been around the world looking and
in addition for some very small
societies of ants and the some of the
smallest you have to find using a crack
team of experts so in this first picture
you see Lloyd Davis and David DiNozzo in
Ecuador looking for the more obscure
ants and this requires that they be very
patient and they actually stare into
these containers full of soil from the
rainforest floor for hours every day
looking for dots that
and those are some of the rarest and
most extraordinary ants and one of the
really cool species we found down there
in Ecuador was baseless eres singularity
and those ants are extraordinarily slow
they move it
well glacial speeds and we found out
through watching this species in their
small societies maybe a dozen
individuals that well it seemed
appropriate these ants actually chased
snails and super slow-mo and so here you
see a snail is making a dramatic a
left-hand turn to try to escape the ants
which is covered itself in mud by the
way perhaps to hide and these are the
characteristics of small societies and
humans to societies accelerate as groups
get bigger why is that well you have
more to gain moving fast in a big city
like New York and the small town you
know who you're gonna see at the coffee
shop you know the coordinates of your
day and what's going to happen in big
cities all kinds of crazy things can
happen you can see an art gallery you
can bump into an ant expert whatever it
is there's a lot of to be gained with
type a behavior so that causes people to
accelerate is what's been discovered you
know for humans seems to be the same
with ants the bigger societies like this
Acrobat ant colony here in Africa there
are individuals flowing past each other
all the time and they actually are
taking in information about what all the
other ants are doing as they pass by so
an ant might discover that a lot of
workers are out there collecting food
and maybe not enough or taking out the
trash and so it may decide what to do
that day based on this information
amount of information flowing through
the colony really accelerates the bigger
the society is both for ants and humans